des cochons des vaches des moutons près
de 3200 bêtes sont mises à l'honneur au
salon international de l'agriculture
et parmi ces animaux des ovins yvelinois
les mérinos de la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet c'était des mérinos au
départ et comme il séjourne depuis plus
de deux siècles à la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet bas ils ont été
rebaptisés mérinos de rambouillet je
participe au jugement des concours de
races ovines sur la qualité des toisons
en tant qu'expert lainiers auprès du
concours général agricole qui a des
critères qui sont communes à toutes les
races notamment l'obésité cirque ont
essayé de rechercher une fibre qui a la
même finesse
depuis les pôles où elle est la plus
fine jusqu'aux hugo où est la plus
grossière prenons de la hauteur pour
rencontrer les producteurs pour sa
deuxième présence sur le salon
la ferme des à lui ai fait découvrir ses
légumes anciens des visiteurs étonné
face à des produits comme le choucas lé
la poire de terre ou la racine de persil
n'était vrai ça se mange pas
ou cuits comme une pomme de terre pour
ça
j'en passe 1
nous posent des questions à bastien
c'était comme ça le salsifis je pensais
pas que ça pue c'est comme ça en plus on
les éduque un petit peu on leur explique
comment le cultiver même les gens qui
sont qui viennent du sud de la france
ils disent 'voilà tient au salon on a vu
des légumes dans l'île de france qui
était formidable pour ce salon
international de l'agriculture 2010 est
les organisateurs attendent plus de 620
mille visiteurs jusqu'au dimanche 5 mars